Sensei, thank you for today.
I saw these for the first time. Are these original scrolls of Daito-ryu?
Yes, these are scrolls issued by Takeda Sokaku sensei. The Hiden Mokuroku 118 techniques.
Let’s have a look.
Yes, please.
Please explain.
I’m going to explain about these scrolls.
The upper one was issued by Takeda Sokaku sensei. It is “Daito-ryu Jujutsu Hiden Mokuroku”.
There is a stamp here.
It says, Takeda Sokaku Hombu-cho.
Specifically, Daito-ryu Jujutsu Hombu-cho Minamoto no Masayoshi is written.
The stamp below is “Take-So”. It means Takeda Soke (head of a school).
The scroll below was issued by Ueshiba Morihei sensei.
It’s title is “Aikijujutsu Hiden Mokuroku”.
Its technical content is the same as that of Daito-ryu Jujutsu Hiden Mokuroku.
I would like to explain while comparing them.
Please.
In the case of Ueshiba sensei’s scroll, the word “Aiki” is included in the title.
Takeda sensei’s one says Daito-ryu Jujutsu.
And similarly, the first technique reads as “attack with your right hand”
This is the same too. I think this technique is Ikkyo.
Shomen-uchi Ikkyo?
Yes, that’s right.
It starts from that technique.
As we look, these are Zatori jujutstu techniques.
What is Zatori?
It means that the techniques are executed from a sitting.
These techniques are followed by Hanza handachi Jujutsu techniques.
In Aikido, these are?
Hanmi Handachi.
It’s the same thing. In Daito-ryu we say Hanza Handachi.
As we compare the two scrolls, their contents are the same.
Where the papers are connected, the ”Take-So” stamp is always put.
As we look, these are standing techniques. Tachi-dori Jujutsu is written.
It is followed by “Nininzume no Koto”. It is Ninin-dori or techniques against two opponents.
Two opponents from both sides?
Yes, two opponents grab the hands from both sides. These techniques apply in this situation.
And this is “Kasadori” or umbrella taking. In Ueshiba sensei’s scroll, the same thing is written.
These are followed by techniques against a situation when the opponent grabs the grip of the sword.
When the samurai was wearing a sword at his waist, the opponent grabs the grip of the sword to prevent the samurai to draw it.
There is a technique for this situation.
And altogether, 118 techniques are listed.
Including 30 Soto-te variations.
The next part, here, says Daito-ryu jujutsu while Ueshiba sensei’s scroll writes Aiki Jujutsu.
If you look at the content of this part, it writes enthusiastic (熱心 nesshin) in both cases.
. I understand, but it's been bought hot, isn't
“Nesshin asakarazu” has the meaning that the practitioner has to be attracted and practice thoroughly.
After that, “keiko wo ketainaku” comes meaning without neglecting training.
It follows as “shori no hataraki” or ability of victory.
“Now, I award you this scroll” it says.
Gishin sezu: without dout
Sessa takuma no ue: through friendly rivalry
Hissho no jutsu: the techniques of sure victory
Kanawa narubeku soro: will come true
Kudan no gotosi: as it is written.
This is how we read it.
The final part of the scroll is the genealogy.
It begins with Emperor Seiwa.
Then, Sadasumi Shin-o
Ueshiba sensei’s scroll also mentions Emperor seiwa and Sadasumi Shin-o.
However, in the case of Ueshiba sensei’s scroll it is followed by Takeda Sokaku sensei and Ueshiba Morihei sensei.
Here, he is written as Ueshiba Moritaka Minamoto no Seigan.
The Daito-ryu scroll follows.
We can see, Shinra Saburo Minamoto no Yoshimitsu.
And then, it’s past down in the Takeda family.
We can see here Takeda Kunitsugu, who moved to Aizu. Then it connects to Takeda Sokaku sensei.
His title is Daito-ryu Jujutsu Hombu-cho and his full name is Takeda Sokaku Minamoto no Masayoshi.
What is interesting is that it’s issued in the September of 1936.
This time is exactly when Hisa Takuma sensei started to learn from Takeda sensei at the Asahi Newspaper.
At the same time as Hisa sensei learned at Asahi
This scroll was given to Kusumoto Koichiro sensei. He was learning from Takeda sensei in Hyogo prefecture, simultaneously.
So Takeda sensei was teaching at both places while taking turns.
I assume it was Kobe where Takeda sensei taught Mr. Kusumoto.
We can find Kusumoto san’s name in the eimeiroku as well.
He was the vice-captain of Meiji University’s sumo club.
Hisa sensei was also experienced in Sumo.
Kusumoto sensei too.
He was 4 dan in Judo.
For him, three scrolls were presented from Takeda Sokaku sensei.
Sensei, the title of Takeda sensei looks different. What’s written here?
It writes 34 generations Aizu warrior.
So it compiles the Takeda family’s lineage in one sentence.
And Ueshiba sensei is written as “monjin” of Takeda sensei.
I might see the first time, Ueshiba sensei using such a name.
What’s the meaning of Minamoto no Seigan?
Perhaps, it’s because Takeda sensei used the Minamoto name.
I think, similarly, Ueshiba sensei called himself Minamoto followed by Seigan.
Sensei, are these different scrolls?
Yes, these are different.
This one is Hiden Okugi no Koto.
It was given from Takeda Sokaku sensei to Kusumoto Koichiro sense, who I already explained earlier.
This is the second scroll of Daito-ryu with 36 techniques.
The techniques are listed.
As we saw earlier, where the pages are connected the “Take-So” stamp is put.
All together 36 techniques.
It says that these techniques on the right are Goshinyo no Te.
It is followed by the same text and lineage.
and it’s dated 1936.
This is the second scroll.
The one below is the third scroll of Daito-ryu.
I think it will be released to the world, but Daito-ryu Aiki
“Daito-ryu Aikijujutus Hiokugi no Koto”
Some people read it as “Ogi”, however, it’s read as “Okugi”.
The stamps are very interesting.
From the third scroll, “Daito-ryu Aiki no Jujutsu” is used. It includes “no”.
Then, Somucho Takeda Sokaku Minamoto no Masayoshi is written.
This stamp is the characteristic of the third scroll. A different stamp is put on it.
There is another characteristic.
The third scroll mentions the name of a technique “Shiho-nage” for the first time.
The techniques seem to be explained in detail.
That’s right.
As far as I know, the third scroll was compiled around this time (1936).
Till that time, only Hiden Mokuroku 118 techniques and this Hiden Okugi no Koto 36 techniques existed.
And later, this Hiokugi scroll was made, I think.
And here, the list goes 118 techniques, Aiki no Jutsu, and Hiden Okugi.
All together 84 techniques.
Jo-chu-ge. All these are colled Goshinyo no Te.
Sensei, What’s the meaning of ura-omote and jo-chu-ge?
There are Omote and Ura forms.
I don’t think that jo-chu-ge simply means upper, middle, and lower.
Regarding this part, further research is necessary.
This third scroll was given to Kusumoto Koichiro sensei.
Usually, at the end of 84 techniques, there is an explanation about Aiki Nito-ken (Aiki two swords)
However, this scroll doesn’t include that part.
During this period, Hisa sensei learned from Takeda sensei in the Kansai area.
We can assume that this scroll is almost identical to the one given to Hisa sensei.
I heard that Hisa sensei’s scroll was destroyed during the war, but probably it didn’t include Aiki Nito ken ether.
Takeda sensei probably didn’t teach these techniques at this time.
Is it Ok?
Thank you very much.
Thank you.